the ocean is often thought of as a
silent wilderness but under the surface
is a symphony of sound sound that marine
creatures rely on for their survival to
find food to communicate to navigate the
lights vanishes metres below the surface
so the sound is really what supports
life in water but humans are
increasingly polluting the ocean with
noise
which is posing a threat to creatures
from the smallest to the most majestic
now we are facing a global issue that
affects thousand species this man is at
the forefront of the science of ocean
sound he's working to dial down the
volume in a bid to protect marine life
around the world
like I said when Ellie grew so did the
dental dilemma in his lab in Barcelona
Michele Andre is conducting an
experiment with an artificial ear
so this is our hydrophone which is the
artificial ear that is able to capture
all the sounds that will send them to
our artificial brain electronics that is
inside his housing the underwater
microphone is being put through its
paces before it's dropped into the
Mediterranean Sea the device is part of
an ambitious experiment to better
understand how human sound is affecting
marine life our perception of sound in
the ocean is biased our ear is not made
to listen underwater
our ear is made to listen in air so for
years and years and years we really
thought that the sea was a world of
silence
Michelle's team is carrying out the
biggest ever sound survey of the world's
ocean dropping hydrophones in multiple
locations and at various depths this
combination of artificial ear artificial
brain press transmission is something
that has given us a human being a sixth
sense that we didn't have and now we can
listen in to the ocean as if we were
dolphins but also we can be anywhere
sound is essential to marine life
because light doesn't travel further
than a few hundred meters underwater
thousands of species use it to
communicate to find their way around to
spot their next meal or ensure they're
not someone else's
it is a harmony of sound that lived
there for millions of years
then as human beings we started to
introduce different sound artificial
sounds through our activities only 100
years ago so this is really recent that
we have started to invade with our sound
Louis pollution is now recognized as a
major threat to ocean life everything
that we do in the ocean introduces sound
that may have an effect on the
environment there are more than 15,000
container ships that sell every day
around the world unlike many other
threats to the ocean noise pollution is
invisible which means it's often
overlooked but in 2002 the world started
to take notice 14 beacons whales
stranded on the holiday beaches of Nan
savatya and we're to Ventura it was
later discovered that multiple ships and
submarines were operating in the area
using sonar pulses of sound used to
detect objects underwater this is the
first time that we could associate as
cost to effective relationship that a
noise introduced by the Navy sonar was
leading to the stranding of his whales
whales talk to each other through a
complex language of clicks and whistles
these sounds help them to navigate and
communicate man-made noises like sonar
can disrupt this communication and
disorientate them we know how sensitive
people are to whales and dolphins totem
animals and they were seeing them washed
on shore by this human activity for the
first time so this really helped
understanding that these noise could
have a detrimental effect since this
incident the use of sonar has been
associated with a large number of whale
strandings around the world
but while beached whales continue to
grab the headlines michelle was keen to
understand if other creatures were
experiencing the same fate
a group of giant squids were found
stranded on the beach
the post-mortem analysis didn't show any
cause of the death what he was about to
discover would change scientists
understanding of the effects of ocean
noise pollution this group of experts
realized that geophysics experiments
using high-energy sounds it was
performed a few days before this event
oil prospecting ships had unknowingly
disturbed the ecosystem below them we
decided in our laboratory to recreate
this situation and we found this massive
a protection when we expose this animal
to sound although squid don't have ears
their bodies contain small organs called
stata cysts which are lined with noise
sensitive hairs in his lab Michelle and
his team discovered that even low
intensity sounds destroy these hairs and
knock out the squids balance we went
through the idea that that was only
affecting a few species the whales are
the Dolphins to invertebrates and fish
and we are speaking about thousands of
species so we cannot anymore consider
the effect of noise as species specific
but consider it as a global effect to
the whole marine environment
this revelation has been the driving
force behind Michelle's plan to map the
soundscape of the entire ocean so the yo
shrimps
this is the sound of a ship passing by
so far he has built and installed 150
listening platforms around the world
what we do is we want to identify all
the sounds right we don't want to leave
anyone a part of this so we want to know
everything to do that we need to train
the system to recognize the features
that belong to one or another source
every sound is being labeled and stored
in what is now the world's biggest
database of ocean sound using artificial
intelligence the sounds in the acoustic
library can be identified as natural or
man-made and the effects they're having
on marine life can be assessed
we aim at building trends that reflect
the biodiversity of an area if we detect
an external event that could be a ship
noise or other human activity that will
influence the area in a negative way we
will see how this trend changes because
of this external factor researchers are
trying to pin down the damage that human
activity is having on the ocean and
they're revealing some concerning trends
noise pollution is most prominent in the
northern hemisphere every decade noise
from shipping has doubled in intensity
which has been seen to have an effect on
certain species of whale reducing their
ability to communicate with each other
by about 60% airguns are the most common
method used to map the ocean floor for
oil and gas exploration their impacts
have been detected 4000 kilometres from
the source and have been linked to
multiple mass strandings the South
Pacific is the part of the ocean with
the least human noise
the good news is that unlike other forms
of pollution the impact from noise is
short-lived
if we compare sound to other source of
pollution as soon as you switch off the
sound the effect is gone but not all
noise is bad and Michel and his team are
trying to ascertain how humans can best
carry out important work while limiting
its effect on the ocean
[Music]
Michel is now working with marine based
industries to help them reduce ocean
noise pollution in our laboratory which
way to understand this effect on the
marine environment so we can provide the
industry that operates at sea with these
tools that will allow them to operate in
the same way with a limited effect on
the environment solutions include noise
reduction technologies to lessen the
sound of deep-sea drilling in the
renewables sector and potential
alternatives to sonar
Michel Andres research is shifting
Sciences understanding of noise
pollution it's just the beginning but
his work could fundamentally change the
way in which humans operate on the ocean
and coexist with marine creatures in the
future
[Music]
hi I'm Claire and I directed this film
if you want to learn more about some of
the greatest challenges facing the ocean
and the people looking to solve them
then click on the link opposite and if
you want to watch more of the protector
series and click on the other link
please subscribe and thank you for
watching